kiev deuxième semaine d'offensive russe
nous nous dirigeons plein sud vers les
zones touchées par les premiers
bombardements passé le qui-vive est une
ville garnison cibles stratégiques
priorités des forces russes voici l
impact très concret depuis l'invasion
militaire de la russie voici un tir de
missile sur cette ville satellitaire à
40 km sud de kiev ceci ce bâtiment est
totalement détruit par ce missile une
violence inouïe et une école il
yad'abord d'ailleurs encore autour de
nous et bien des cahiers d'écoliers des
vêtements et même un goûter d'écoliers
qui est encore restée là qui montre bien
la violence qui a pu frapper cet
établissement
je pense à tous mes amis qui ont étudié
ici dans cette école
je pense aussi à ce vieux monsieur qui
travaillait ici
c'est vraiment atroce pour tous ces gens
et les enfants qui étaient ici à la
mairie de vassil kif volontaires
militaires et forces de défense
s'activent 24 heures sur 24 dans les
sous-sols vivent plus d'une centaine
d'habitants réfugiés ludmila était
enseignante pour l'école pour bardet
elle s'occupe désormais des familles
cachés ici yu et vous pensez que vous
allez devoir un moment un autre partir
non pas question nous restons c'est
notre ville ici et pour aller où tous
ceux qui vivent ici ont décidé de rester
on ne va pas s'enfuir
on va se battre
nous prendrons les décisions qui
s'imposent nous trouveront toujours un
moyen de tenir nous n'avons pas de doute
nous sommes ici depuis quatre jours sans
sortir
la nuit dernière était assez calme ça va
la situation a cassé le cube est à
l'image de la réalité ukrainienne une
implacable avancé russe et une
population déterminée à résister
ils sont attachants